bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france on est quand même très loin avec
ce partenariat franco grec du
méga-contrat des douze sous marins
vendus à l'australie pour la modique
somme de 56 milliards d'euros
c'est sûr que comme on dit là il ya un
problème de taille cela dit pour les
chantiers français les chantiers de
lorient
il est retombé n'était pas aussi
extraordinaire puisque l'essentiel de la
construction des sous marins devait se
faire en australie naturellement ça
donnait quand même beaucoup de travail
au bureau d'études et il ya les
forcément y avoir
un nombre important de deux pièces
fabriquées et exporté depuis la france
maintenant le contrat grecque je ne sais
pas ce qu'on peut appeler ça une
compensation parce que c'était
évidemment en discussion de longue date
france grèce italie
plus dur exercice naval cette année le
prochain a lieu en mars il autre a dû
avoir lieu en juin donc ça fait déjà
longtemps qu'il ya une coopération et
j'imagine qu'un contrat de 3 milliards
soit un milliard par frégates c'est
quelque chose qui a dû être
conclu en amont et bien avant que
l'australie ne non ce sous la pression
américaine est offerte la vente des
trois frégates quelles peuvent être les
autres retombées économiques de cette
coopération avec la nes
il est
là
on avait déjà vu la grèce commandé
12 à fall
+26 d'occasion racheter à l'armée
française donc on voit quand même que la
grèce a beaucoup commandé auprès de la
france alors je pourrai complété en
disant que l'ours qui concerne les
navires
ça sera en plus de ça l'occasion de leur
vendre les équipements missiles sol air
missile de type exocet donc anti forces
navales
donc il va y avoir évidemment
tout un tout un panel de matériel qui va
être commandés et qui si j'ose dire est
un petit peu du consommable donc il y
aura renouvellement certainement de
commandes de certains matériaux alors je
ne sais pas quelles pourraient être les
prochaines commandes de la grèce la
grèce est la
206 la qualité à défendre je sais pu
enfin les décomptes c'est entre 1200 et
cinq mille îles dans la mer egée mais en
tout cas de 200 sont habitées donc il ne
rend pas plus ils n'auront pas trop de
trois frégates pour faire le job surtout
qu'en fait il y en aura jamais que deux
en mer en permanence voilà donc je ne
sais pas si
la grèce pourrait être à son tour
intéressé par par des sous-marins
pourquoi pas je sais que là ils peuvent
aussi se tourner éventuellement vers
l'allemagne malgré ou pas après un
sévère coup avec l'annulation du contrat
austral air est ce que ce nouveau
contrat grec va effectivement lui
permettre de rebondir ou bien c'est
réellement anecdotique
non c'est évidemment pas et nautiques
surtout que là je pense que c'est
vraiment du travail pour pour le
chantier de lorient donc là ça va être
du made in france
mais naturellement ça ne peut pas
compenser la perte du contrat avec avec
l'australie maintenant ça va donner du
travail je crois juste que jusque vers
2026 parce que j'ai compris en tout cas
les livraisons devraient commencer en
2025 et 2026
par ailleurs
navale groupe va également construire 5
cinq frégates de type belharra pour la
france donc ça on fait 8 et là je pense
qu'effectivement du du boulot pour pour
2030 mais il faut encore je dis ça ne
peut pas compenser la perte du contrat
australien et ça serait venu s'ajouter
tout simplement donc pas par une
compensation alors justement concernant
l'annulation de ce contrat de sous
marins avec l'australie est ce que la
france au final va s'y retrouver
financièrement qu'est ce qui se trame
aujourd'hui entre les deux parties en
termes de compensations
je ne connais pas les termes et je pense
que
à part l'entourage médias
des manuels macron et le jean yves le
drian je ne sais pas à combien se
montent les compensations elles sont
certainement élever mais ça fait partie
évidemment des
aspects top secret d'un contrat
maintenant ce qu'on aimerait tous
connaître aussi c'est quels moyens de
pression les états unis ont pu employer
quitte à payer un dédit très important
j'imagine qu'il va falloir que les états
unis tiennent compte du dédit que les
australiens vont devoir verser pour la
rupture du contrat donc il faut que les
américains qu'on pense ça mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas vraiment un
problème pour eux je me demande de la
même façon qu'est-ce que caisse les
américains ont bien pu offrir aux
suisses pour les convaincre d'acheter
donc des f 35 qui sont pas opérationnels
où il n'y a pas même pas de simulateurs
aujourd'hui
fonctionnel plutôt que le rafale qui
fonctionne bien donc on voit bien que
les etats unis ils sont prêtes à tout
écraser ils ont je crois des moyens
illimités et le fait de devoir payer un
dédit ou de participer à ce paiement
certains aiment leur faire peur du tout
merci pour votre éclairage à un philippe
béchade rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur
en chef de la lettre des affranchis